from the time we're born we spend an
inordinate amount of time studying each
other's faces
as babies we can recognize that big
smile
that we see of that caring mother
looking down
on us and so forth but we're confronted
with many
variants of that just take a look at
these
all examples of smiles some come to us
they're very genuine some are a little
reserved some are a little nervous
they're all smiles but what are they
communicating
my name is joe navarro and for 25 years
i was a
spy catcher for the fbi you may be
familiar with my previous video
i talked about body language there's
just no pinocchio effect
and people who prattle that and say well
we can detect deception because the
person
touches their nose or covers their
mouths that's just sheer nonsense
and today we're going to focus on the
face
when it comes to non-verbals the face
is key there's so much information
and feelings that we receive from the
face
that for us the face takes primacy
so one of the ways to to look at the the
face
is to think of it in two areas comfort
and discomfort because
really that's how the brain reacts to
the world
so let's start with psychological
comfort
when we're very comfortable the muscles
of the face
become very relaxed and we have all the
behaviors that are associated with it
smiling laughing usually the pupils
are slightly wider the lips are full
and usually the chin tends to be further
out
the very second that there's
psychological discomfort
usually it begins to register in several
areas now for some people
will see it in the forehead and here
between the eyes
where they'll be furrowing of the
forehead or
squinting and of course the tucking down
of the chin
or in some instances where something is
really emotional
you'll see the chin begins to vibrate
covering of the eyes also is a display
of psychological discomfort so our faces
what we feel in that moment is
immediately displayed
by our nonverbals and the easiest way to
look at it is
is that behavior consistent with comfort
or is it consistent with
discomfort one of the questions that i'm
often asked is
how do we read each other how do we read
each other's faces
we start with the hair how it's combed
what color it is is it dry is it wet
is it curly is it this arranged
as children we play with each other's
hair
we look at each other's hair we
immediately notice
when it's wet or dry or it's changed in
some form
we look at the forehead for information
when it's smooth
the forehead tells us that everything is
well
and placid when it's furrowed
we begin to notice that perhaps there's
some sort of
discomfort the eyebrows
you know the arching of the eyebrows is
our exclamation point doing that
eyebrow flash when we see someone we
recognize and we go hey
how are you the glabella this little
area between the eyes
someone says something we don't like and
we might squint at them and look at them
as scans
the nose do we wrinkle our nose
upward we do that bunny nose at about
three months of age babies are already
doing this when
they don't like something they're being
offered and then there's the lips
which convey so much information maybe
as often as the eyes i'm asked about
smiles
we have the social smile
the interested smile
a curious smile
we have little secretive smiles that we
might give to
someone that we're interested in there
is so much
to our mouths it's it's so expressive
but starting at a very young age
we're already focusing on these things
you may not notice for instance the
pupils
whether they're wide or narrowed but
subconsciously your brain
is assessing this information there's
just
so much there so we never stop
communicating with our faces it is
something that is
always telegraphing our emotions
and our sentiments and sometimes even
our desires
one of the things that was startling to
me when studying
faces was what i had been picking up
for decades when i look back on the lone
ranger
watching the movies of zorro or
even batman and robin one of the things
you notice is
all these good guys were wearing masks
that covered the eyes
but the bad guys always covered their
mouths so the bank robbers would wear
a bandana and then just pull it over
their faces
undoubtedly we are being affected by the
fact that we cannot see the full face
i mean we first had reporting of this
right after world war one
where we saw the horrors of that war
and soldiers who had their faces somehow
ameliorated they had to wear these masks
and even
with mass they still were not being
received well into society and so
there has always been something
unsettling about
not being able to see the full face and
i think it has to do with the fact that
we get so much information
from there but
even with mass we can still communicate
with each other we can still
understand what people are trying to say
and you can pick up above the line of
the mask
look at this clip notice that
even though they're wearing a mask we
can still see the emotions behind that
mask
we can still decode that face now
obviously you're not going to see lip
compression
but with some people you really see it
both
in the forehead and in the glabella
region
of the eyes and then of course in the
orbits of the eyes there's a lot of
squinting so
for some people it doesn't matter that
you can't see their mouth you'll
certainly see it
in their face but you know the rest of
the body is
transmitting information if we can't see
the full face
where can we go the neck the shoulders
right
the hands the fingers the thumbs in
particular right so when we emphasize
the fingers are wide
when we lack emphasis our fingers come
together even our
feet communicate sentiments so we have
to redirect where we're getting
information but
always remember that from the time we're
born we're looking at the
face for that information we just have
to be patient with ourselves
and know that there's still information
out there we may just have to get it
from other parts of the body
a lot of us now are doing these uh video
conferences
zoom google meets and and so forth and
the visual range has changed completely
because now we're only seeing maybe from
the chest up
maybe we're only seeing the face one of
the things we know
is that in face-to-face meetings this
tends to be on a subconscious level very
aggressive so
directly looking at another person as i
am
now directly looking at the lens is
actually creating
discomfort that we actually get greater
comfort
when we turn slightly it makes the other
person
relaxed and one of the mistakes that i'm
finding on
zoom calls and google meets and other
environments
is this very direct intense look at the
lens
so one of the things that you can try
next time you're on a
video call is angle yourself and
see if you find that more comfortable
see if it's more relaxed see if in
doing that behavior that the other
person then does the same thing
they feel a little bit more relaxed
maybe they lean back a little bit more
one of the things that i teach is that
synchrony is harmony
so the more that i can get
the other party to relax
to mirror my behaviors
the more i know that we are in synchrony
and that's powerful
because we are both engaging each other
at a conscious and at a subconscious
level
so about 30 years ago while
still working for the fbi and conducting
thousands of interviews i began to
notice
that there were times when i would look
at a face
and there was just something odd about
it
i couldn't quite pinpoint what i was
seeing
and so i began to think about the
concept of
chirality and chirality usually
in in chemistry means that when you fold
something over
it looks like it's going to fold over
perfectly but in fact
it doesn't and that's what i found with
faces
sometimes when someone presents in a way
that
they're difficult to interpret it's
because
their faces are actually showing
two emotions one on the left and one in
the right
and if you divide the face in half and
just cover
one half of the face you'll be able to
more clearly see
what that specific emotion is take a
look at these photographs
now these photographs are taken during
emotionally
charged moments and when you first
see the face you may look at it and say
well there's something going on there
but it's not
till you cover perfectly one half
and then cover the other half that you
begin to
see the real gross differences
normally when we feel an emotion
we see it fully on both sides of the
face
but because we don't see the full
emotion on the whole face
that's something that we need to focus
on and determine
why because something isn't right
why do we focus so much on the face
we focus on the face because of
necessity
because through our faces we can show
that we care
through our faces we can validate
what others are going through and so
by studying the faces of others we gain
understanding about ourselves
realizing that our body language
will affect others positively and that's
why we study non-verbals
we study non-verbals because it benefits
us
but it also benefits others